bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles
émission spéciale avec nous deux poids
lourds de la vie politique européennes
daniel cohn bendit et guy verhofstadt
ils ne sont pas du même bord
mais ils ont écrit un livre ensemble sur
l'europe fédérale et la première
question que nous posons à nos invités
et celle du budget européen qui va payer
pour l'europe 900 960 9 190 mille
milliards d'euros combien d'argent pour
le budget européen enjeux fixés l'
enveloppe financière pour les sept
prochaines années
la bataille est lancée il y a ceux qui
veulent dépenser plus une alliance de 15
pays emmené par la pologne la grèce
l'estonie ou encore malte et qui
refusent que les fonds européens ne
fasse les frais de l'austérité
et puis il ya ceux qui au contraire ne
veulent pas donner un euro de plus parmi
eux la france l'allemagne la finlande le
danemark le royaume uni ou encore les
pays-bas
la plupart sont contributeurs nets au
budget c'est à dire qu'il met plus
d'argent que les autres au pot commun
le premier ministre néerlandais explique
que son pays a pris des mesures
drastiques pour contrer la crise et que
la rigueur s'applique à tous david
cameron menacent de son côté de sortir
son veto si le budget augmente même la
commission européenne a proposé de
baisser l'enveloppent de 50 milliards
d'euros
mais si le budget est réduit il n'y aura
plus d'argent pour financer tous les
programmes européens en même temps la
politique agricole commune le fonds
social européen même erasmus est menacée
de disparition
et bientôt il n'y aura plus d'argent
pour l'aide alimentaire réservé aux plus
démunis ni même pour les fonctionnaires
européens qui ont battu le pavé à
bruxelles
alors s'il n'y a plus d'argent dans les
caisses qui va payer pour l'europe
alors qui va payer pour l'europe c'est
la question du moment que nous allons
katia posée à nos deux invités deux
invités exceptionnels guy verhofstadt
bonjour vous êtes président ici de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe vous avez été
premier ministre belge pendant près de
dix ans et daniel cohn bendit
coprésident l âme était projet mini
coprésident du groupe des verts et vous
avez écrit à 80 cet ouvrage de boules
europe un cri qui s'adresse aux
gouvernants et également aux citoyens
européens appellent à créer une
véritable fédération européenne sinon
dites vous l'europe dans dix quinze ans
n'existera plus alors guy verhofstadt le
budget européen c'est l'actualité du
moment on voit que les dirigeants
européens est d'ailleurs le parlement
européen c'est charpy ne sont pas
d'accord est ce que vous pensez que
c'est symptomatique d'un problème au
niveau européen aujourd'hui il faut
naturellement reconnaître que chaque
chaque fois quand il ya un budget il ya
la lutte entre les états d'une part et
certains états entre eux et le parlement
européen ce que le parlement européen
j'ai surtout c'est créer de changer le
budget d'une façon très important très
radical c'est de dire qu'il y a des
ressources propres à l'intérieur du
musée ça veut dire que les citoyens
dorénavant vont payer directement à
l'union européenne plutôt que de passer
par des contributions nationales le
point sur les états européens ne veulent
pas de ça ouais je ne sais pas et a
beaucoup d états qui sont en faveur
aussi de sa sécu pas parce que si vous
avez des ressources propres donc une
sorte de financement direct des citoyens
vers l'union européenne alors les
contributions nationales peuvent baisser
de boeuf être diminuée alors quand on
voit daniel cohn-bendit les déclarations
des dirigeants européens
françois hollande qui a dit on il faut
plus d'europe etc et quand on voit que
ici en fait personne ne veut payer pour
ceux plus d'europe c'est qu'elle vote
révélateur il ya d'abord ce que vaut ce
que vous l'on ne voit pas assez
l'extérieur une véritable rupture à
l'intérieur du conseil européen vous
avez les 15 pays 15
pays sur 27 qui sont les pays des fonds
de cohésion qui sont radicalement contre
la position anglaise et contre la
pollution allemande et ils ne savent pas
trop bien quelle est la position
française met donc c'est pas vrai que
c'est le parlement contre les
gouvernements jamais disons les tensions
à l'intérieur du concert et ont été
aussi forte
je parle sous contrôle de geek il a fait
partie du grand saigne c'est vrai ça on
le voit qui est hui hier une réunion de
15 chefs de gouvernement des pays des
fonds cozian à l'intérieur de l'enceinte
du parlement européen
ça veut bien dire que donc que c'est pas
simplement parlement contre conseil
deuxièmement il faut comprendre que pour
certains pays
le budget européen c'est le seul moyen
de relancer de redéployer l'économie
pour certains évidemment pas pour l'un
pays comme l'allemagne ou la france mais
pour certains pays c'est le budget
européen avec les fonds cohésion qui est
le seul moyen de relancer c'est pour
cela et qui a raison la taxe sur les
transactions financières la taxe sur les
provinces et des ressources propres pour
le bras et ça fait baisser la
contribution nationale des pays qui
justement lève une taxe sur les
transactions ont augmenté le contrôle de
citoyens parce que si les citoyens doit
payer directement l'union européenne
il va être intéressé ce qui se passe
avec son argent il va y avoir une
contrôle beaucoup plus intense des
citoyens envers l'union européenne mais
aussi au niveau de la démocratie c'est
un énorme pas en avant cette idée les
ressources propres
mais quand même aujourd'hui ce qu'on
constate c'est une division assez forte
entre ces deux camps dont vous parlez ce
que vous pensez qu'ils sont en train de
discuter il faut le dire sur un ton sans
importance et quoi comparer ça avec les
états unis
les etats unis ont un budget de 24 pour
cent de leur produit intérieur brut
moi je pense que c'est justement le fait
qu'on a un budget aussi in important et
qui est la cause de notre crise autour
de l'euro parce que l'euro est soutenu
par quoi l'union monétaire et soutenues
parfois pas les années tout il n'y a pas
d'autorité fédéral derrière n'a pas de
budget il n'y a pas de marché
obligataire derrière donc le fait qu'on
se dispute sur un budget d'environ 1% et
que les états unis ont vingt quatre fois
un budget plus important c'est ça aussi
le coeur de la crise autour d'eux le
rouge alors l'europe fédérale
vous avez prononcé le mot c'est ce que
vous défendez dans le livre que vous
avez écrit ensemble alors vous n'êtes
pas du même bord politique alors nous
sommes rendus ici au parlement européen
et nous avons demandé à certains de vos
collègues députés européens ce qu'il
pensait de votre ouvrage regarder cet
art portage signé thibault le floch cher
katia schaer françois aujourd'hui je
suis parti à la pêche n'ont pas ce genre
de pêche mais plutôt à la pêche aux
députés et ceci est mon ami
moi je viens voir les députés pendant
demandé est ce que oui vous aussi vous
voulez une offre fédéral ou non surtout
pas il nous faut un échelon pouvoir
fédéral au niveau européen pour moi y'a
pas d'autres c'est la théorie tout le
monde et pour le fédéralisme mais en
réalité mais en réalité quand on met le
sujet sur la table
c'est là
pourquoi on n'a pas encore d'europe
général est ce parce qu'on n'a pas
encore une crise jusqu'à ce moment mais
au moment de crise en paquet il faut
bien le faire si c'est ou fédéraliser
pour faire la même chose pour continuer
à mener les mêmes politiques qui nous
mène dans le mur ben l'europe ira
simplement plus vite dans le voilà
angela merkel
on va voir si elle a lu le savait
difficile
bon désolé daniel notre compatriote n'a
pas voulu de votre livre on a essayé
vous avez lu ce livre
désolé je suis pressé on propose un
gouvernement européen avec des ministres
européens et même un président européen
élu par tous les européens c'est quelque
chose qui vous réjouit ou pas et c'est
beaucoup trop vite à mon avis alors que
le propose pourquoi pas dès 2014 c'est
beaucoup trop vite aussi à aider je suis
totalement contre le fédéralisme car
nous avons des cultures trop différentes
les allemands ne seront jamais comme les
grecs et les grecs l'adn européen c'est
un peu baroque 1
et pour finir nous sommes allés par les
prêts des lits avec le chef de file des
eurosceptiques fauteuil week end l'amour
du ciel nous ne pouvons pas avoir une
europe où la grèce et l'allemagne
partagent la même monnaie
c'est impossible en fait ce n'est pas un
système fédéral qu'il propose c'est une
forme d'union centralisée avec un
gouvernement qui n'est pas démocratique
vous êtes dur c'est ça qu'ils proposent
ce qu'ils appellent de leurs voeux
c'est que les institutions de bruxelles
dont la plupart des dirigeants ne sont
pas élus et d'immenses pouvoirs au
détriment des états au final ce sont de
dangereux fanatiques
oui des fanatiques dangereux en fait ce
sont tous les nationalistes des neurones
nationaliste et rien ne les arrêtera
tant qu'ils n'auront pas leur empire
marseille à wil en pire carrément j'ai
l'impression messieurs que pour
convaincre vos collègues du bien fondé
du fédéralisme il faudra vraiment que la
force soit avec vous
on entend des ces réactions mitigées
certains ont peur certains parlent de
dit que vous êtes de dangereux
fédéralistes que vous la répondez moi je
ne me fait pas peur vous savez comme
s'ils faraj aurait dit que il est
d'accord avec nous je me suis tout de
suite ses dires il ya quelque chose qui
marche pas donc c'est évident que lui
c'est un nationaliste et d'ailleurs je
crois que il veut que l'angleterre sorte
de l'union européenne peut-être que
c'est la solution pour l'angleterre est
comme ça on sera débarrassé du chantage
permanent qu'au fond les gouvernements
anglais que ça soit un gouvernement
d'ailleurs social-démocrate anglais ou
conservateurs c'est toujours le chantage
face à l'europe
et puis deuxièmement on veut pas c'est
pas vrai on explique qu'on veut pas
super et allaiter fédéral c'est autre
chose et surtout il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut
dans trente ans plus aucun pays de
l'union européenne danner ne fera partie
du g8
et c'est les autres c'est les autres les
vrais empire qui nous domineront qu'elle
soit la chine que ça soit les états unis
même le brésil et ça et nous faut savoir
ce qu'on veut c'est tout alors vous
parlez du topic plausible qu'est ce que
ça veut dire vous dites c'est comme une
utopie mais elle est plausible elle ça
veut dire que évidemment on se projette
dans l'avenir et on sait que l'europe
fédérale elle viendra pas tout de suite
les pas d'ailleurs c'est pas vrai ce que
dit votre journaliste qu'on a dit qu'on
veut le faire en 2014 devrait pas dire
n'importe quoi non plus mais voilà
pourquoi les de la terre vivante
oui mais c'est pas la même chose et le
viol de 10h en est là il faut changer
les traités ça va mettre c'est un
processus
mais c'est après on est on est dans le
brouillard est là maintenant on a une
boussole donner un cap et ondes et voilà
c'est vers là alors ça mettra 10 ans 15
ans 20 ans mais on sait que les
perspectives c'est l'europe et moi
j'aimerais comprendre pendant universal
où vous voulez aller exactement parce
que derrière le mot europe fédérale on
peut mettre effectivement tout ce qu'on
veut ça serait quoi ça serait c'est en
sait mettre en place d'un gouvernement
européen qui est responsable devant le
parlement européen d'une part et devant
une deuxième chambre qui cela une
chambre qui va représenter les états
nations
de l'union européenne s'est créé aussi
trésorerie théorie européenne un
ministre des finances européen mais
c'est à dire aussi plus loin un marché
obligataire européen
la défense européenne parce qu'on pense
que ce sera beaucoup mieux d'avoir
l'armée européenne
et puis c'est créer naturellement une
force au niveau 2 du monde au niveau
mondial qui peut faire regagner la
souveraineté pour les citoyens européens
parce qu'il faut le dire aujourd'hui le
problème dans le monde globalisé
d'aujourd'hui c'est que les gens ont
peur de ne pas de plus avoir leur destin
en main il y à l'europe fédérale permet
de garantir la souveraineté pas au
niveau national où on l'a perdue pour le
moment mais le dollar regagne un haut
niveau
qu'est-ce qui reste au niveau national
justement à beaucoup de choses de toute
l'implémentation l'exécution de toutes
les stratégies qui ont été convenues au
niveau fédéral au niveau européenne
donc ça reste les états nations ne vont
pas disparaître mais on dit que c'est au
niveau européen qu'il faut créer une
démocratie européenne
une stratégie économique européenne
parce qu'autrement on va jamais sorti un
bras qui le problème de la crise de
autour de leurs aujourd'hui c'est que on
a dix-sept gouvernement différent des
églises des finances différents 17
marchés obligataires et que ça ne peut
pas marcher l'école la santé la culture
veille à yahia il ya peut-être des
normes disons espace politique qui ne
seront pas réglés au niveau filaire est
ce que vous pensez que le citoyen est
prêt à répondre présent à votre appel
est ce que est ce que quand on a fait
les traités de rome
est ce que quand ils ont commencé à se
parler les français les allemands dans
les années 50 est ce que les français
étaient prêts à faire la paix comme ça
avec les allemands n'ont aujourd'hui
nous en tant que responsables politiques
ont il faut proposer quelque chose de
citoyens pour faire avancer le
schmilblick et il est évident que les
sites les citoyens aujourd'hui quand on
en parle d'europe fédérale ils disent
qu'est ce que c'est avec raison et des
bons ça qu'on a écrit ce livre pour
l'imam avait expliqué qu'elle est notre
vision de l'europe fédérale et puis il
faut gagner il faut conquérir les
citoyens c'est ça la politique aussi
aurait un véritable contrôle
démocratique qui n'ont jamais le jour
on a beaucoup trop d'hommes politiques
en europe qui suit simplement l'opinion
publique et qui s'est dit à l'opinion
publique et aux mosquées petits coups et
farouchement populiste nationaliste
alors que je deviens aussi nationaliste
chorale est ce que ça donne avec la
grèce et l'allemagne et les pays on suit
le café du commerce
et donc on dit non non non et on fait le
contraire mais on est obligé de le faire
en catimini on dit jamais la vérité
on ne veut pas dire oui la grèce aura
besoin aujourd'hui d'un rééchelonnement
de la dette on veut pas le dire on va
perdre des milliards parce qu'on n'ose
pas le dire et c'est donc nous on veut
on comprend notre rôle en tant que
disons responsables politiques de
proposer et de se battre pour des idées
alors ça vous êtes dans votre rôle parce
que vous j'ai envie de dire vous vous
bousculer les choses
guy verreault chat vous avez été premier
ministre alors d'un état un petit peu
particulier puisque les géants veut dire
il est fédéraliste dans l'âme c'est la
belgique mais est-ce que vous pouvez
comprendre par exemple qu'un françois
hollande qui vient d'être élu à la tête
de la république française et du mal à
dire pour écoutez moi je vais perdre une
partie de mes pouvoirs vous m'avez élu
pour quelque chose
et de toute façon on va rapidement
transféré sa haut niveau au niveau
européen ce qui sans doute d'abord on
demande pas la france devenir un état
fédéral
donc c'est pas simplement on demande de
coopérer ensemble avec la france pour
faire de l'union européenne une
organisation fédérale c'est ça qu'on
veut faire et deuxièmement c'est
toujours difficile naturellement de
données d'être pouvoir à une autre
instance par exemple supranationale même
si les démocrates y mais on n'a pas le
choix dans le monde demain c'est comme
dany l'a dit tantôt dans le g8 de demain
il n'y a aucun pays européen qui va
encore être représenté le jury dès
demain c'est quoi c'est la russie et les
etats unis le japon la chine l'inde le
brésil et puis le mexique et l'indonésie
voilà l'égérie de demain donc si on veut
encore compter si on veut encore
défendre nos intérêts notre modèle
social
au niveau mondial il faut le faire
ensemble dans un union fédérale votre
question il y avait une erreur cherchez
l'erreur l'erreur c'est que la france
croit avoir aujourd'hui le président la
france une souveraineté internationale
qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a plus même voix
yémen dans l'intervalle
sur libye la france et l'angleterre au
bout d'une semaine il avait plus de
munitions ils ont demande ils ont dû
demander aux anglais et aujourd'hui la
france n'a pas l'argent pour avoir la
larme et d'intervention nécessaires dans
certains conflits
donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui cette idée
de la france parce que la france est au
conseil de sécurité ou à dison la
défense atomique m tout ça c'est du
blabla c'est fini et c'est ça qu'il faut
expliquer aux français où on est plus à
paris ou ailleurs
le le pouvoir n'est plus dans une
capitale européenne et l'est dans une
capitale commune le pouvoir on le peut
la voir en commun on peut reconquérir
nos souverainetés en commun où on la
perd de plus en plus alors laurent
existe-t-elle encore sur la scène
internationale entre la toute puissance
chinoise et américaine
reste-t-il une place pour l'union
européenne réponse avec ce zapping des
télés ropéenne dont les institutions
européennes
on espère que cette réélection permettra
de boucler l'accord de libre-échange
entre les vingt-sept et les états unis
mais les relations sous le premier
mandat d'obama n'ont pas toujours été
idylliques de temps en temps nous avons
senti une certaine fatigue et frappés
dans la relation entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis une fatigue
ressentie aussi outre atlantique l égard
de européen jugé trop divisés la
nouvelle administration obama pourrait
dès lors s'avérer plus exigeantes
obama jingping les maîtres du monde et
l'europe dans tout cela une un sing rien
en anglais ou rien en chinois
pas un mot dans le discours d'obama
mardi soir pas plus que durant toute la
campagne signe du déclin de l'europe
certains disent même de sa décadence
lorsque là nous avons toujours eu les
états unis de notre côté barack obama et
le secrétaire d'état au trésor timothy
geitner soutiennent nos positions notre
volonté d'avoir un euro fort de
consolider la monnaie unique est de
garder la grèce dans la zone euro
l'amérique qui se profile dans les
années 2015 2025 ce sera une amérique
qui n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
celle de 1945
c'est une amérique qui va se replier de
plus en plus et qui va revenir à la
stabilisation de la de la montée en
puissance chinoise et de la
stabilisation de l'asie donc il y aura
moins d'amérique en europe 1 regarde
donc la réalité est hélas encore avec
est-ce que vous pensez que le déclin de
l'europe a déjà commencé c'est pas le
déclin c'est qu'on a passée augmenté en
puissance on n'est pas en déclin
l'europe aujourd'hui est bloqué on a
fait des pas en avant cette union
européenne existe l'europe les états
membres aujourd'hui ne sont plus dans
l'état on l'était en 1945 ou en 1950
mais maintenant il faut faire un
troisième saut en avant donc je sais pas
vrai qu'un d'éclat on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le monde change et dans
ce monde qui change
il faut que l'europe change aussi
puisque changement c'est pas aussi un
changement
j'ai envie dire de leader de leaders
politiques ont parlé tout à l'heure du
contrôle démocratique
est-ce que vous pensez que les citoyens
européens ont envie par exemple des
dirigée par josé manuel barroso et
herman van rompuy serre n'a rien de
personnel écouter est ce que metz que
ces instituts et français avaient envie
d'être dirigé par sarkozy non mais avec
un goûter pour lui oui après ils ont pas
voté pour lui
non mais tu es à sa personne a voté pour
jouer dans le petit livre connaît créé
ensemble on propose justement une
procédure pour cela c'est une réforme où
le président de la commission le
président du conseil ce serait se
réfugie en israël le même poste même
honda deuxièmement ce serait élu si
possible directement par par tous les
citoyens européens
et puis il y aurait des listes
transnationales possibilité aussi
d'envoyer envers le parlement européen
des gens aussi il eut pas
des citoyens donc la démocratie
européenne il faut la créer parce
qu'elle n'existe elles existent pour le
mans series parlement européen mais
n'est pas suffisant et on peut on peut
remédier facilement à tout ça vous fait
alors c'est une des propositions n'est
pas tous d'accord sur toutes les
propositions mais vous dites vous faites
les élections européennes vous faites
les lésions par lise comme vous l'avez
maintenant et vous avez deux un deuxième
bulletin
et avec ce bulletin vous et en même
temps la même élection vous allez élire
le président de la commission et de
l'europe
un veau dont vous avez un but un élan là
il y aura une légitimité qui aura un
deuxième tour après quinze jours après
vous aurez une légitimité du président
de l'union européenne élu au suffrage
universel en même temps que l'élection
parlementaire donc pas comme en france
il ya près d elle domination de lune
élections sur l'eau eh bien vous auriez
alors un sursaut démocratique de
l'europe par exemple ce qui se
trouverait une personnalité comme ça
européenne capable de susciter la dite
de l'adhésion de tintin maximum de
citoyens oft a tout donné comme il n'est
pas d'accord vous serez pas d'accord
alors l'est d'ailleurs un débat
intéressant et utile à tous les deux
assis à vinyliques c'est le seul moi je
dis que ce serait plus candidat
mais si par hasard pour ce pur si par
hasard il décidé qu'il y ait une
direction en même temps direct suffrage
universel du président l'union moi je
suis candidat je suis candidat je serai
candidat je serai candidat en grèce sur
les listes parlementaire et serait
candidat pour être président de libéro
chatou serez conduits là bas je serai
candidat en tout cas maintenant prendre
des élections comme pm 2014 mais c'est
vrai que il y a une faiblesse pour
moment de la commission européenne dont
tout le travail qu'on fait et ce qui est
aussi à la base la crise
oui la règle est de la commission c'est
les gouvernements ont voulu ce ce
président est exactement mais
normalement un président de la
commission la commission européenne a
droit d'initiative seules instances
européennes qui peut le faire qui peut
déposer des projets qui peut déposer des
textes législatifs
elle ne fait pas pour le moment elle
attend d'abord le feu vert de paris et
de berlin avant de bouger alors que dans
cette crise il faut des gens avec des
visites
avec des réformes et très radical pour
sauver l'euro et c'est ça qui manque
pour vous avez pris les devants en tout
cas est ce que vous seriez prêt
éventuellement à vous présenter sous une
bannière purement fédéral non moi je
n'en non ça c'est l'idée de guy moi je
ne me représenterai pas sauf s'il y
avait cette élection au suffrage
universel du président de la commission
ce qui ne sera pas le cas parce qu'il
pourrait changer rapidement mais je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui il faut
avancer dans une procédure où il ya des
plus de légitimation démocratique liées
aux élections parlementaires du
président de la commission moi j'essaie
de rassembler tous les pro européens
pour se battre en 2014 parce que
finalement je crois que ce sont
seulement les citoyens qui peuvent faire
changer cette europe
dans le second acte est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment tous les deux que votre
livre qui a été publié déjà il ya
quelques semaines qui est d'ailleurs
traduit dans de plus en plus de langues
au niveau européen il ya maintenant onze
langues
est ce que vous allez sentiment déjà que
c'est en train de faire bouger un peu
les lignes là on en parle comme à 7,7
oui voilà on fait un jouet mais surtout
que cette c'est devenu un débat ouvert
aussi dans le parlement européen de ceux
qui disent non c'est trop radical et
caetera et il nous qui disons non c'est
c'est la seule voie réaliste parce que
ceux qui disent que c'est de l'utopie
aussi irréaliste et présenter cela c'est
la situation actuelle qui était qui
n'est pas réaliste de penser qu'on peut
sortir va crise autour de l'euro et de
la critique et économique par par des
2000 mesures comme on a vu les trois
dernières arrivées je vous fais un pari
françois hollande va parler au parlement
européen en novembre ou en décembre je
sais pas quoi vous serez surpris parce
qu'il devra dire quelque chose sur
l'europe et en fin de compte
évidemment qu'il ne citera pas mais il
devra répondre aux questions aux
propositions qu'on fait dans ce livre je
crois que les responsables politiques ne
peuvent pas échapper au débat qu'on a
lancé il ya quand même des beaucoup de
progrès faits avec la mise en place d'un
mécanisme européen de sauvetage d'une
union bancaire en tout cas les premières
les premières pierres sont lancées
un contrôle budgétaire pour éviter que
les pays fassent ce qu'ils veulent dans
leur coin ca c
les regarde et je regardais la
supervision bancaire il ya deux ans le
parlement européens le présentent leur
colle aux l'allemagne dis jamais jamais
deux ans après où la maman on a fait une
erreur on pourra faire d'être au top
parce que justement on a pas de boussole
donc on réagit aux réagi face à la
réalité qui nous imposent des décisions
au lieu d'être maîtres de la stratégie
nos décisions c'était que vous dites que
l'europe maintenant on doit cesser de
réagir aux événements doit prendre à
avoir une boussole une orientation
on y va on y va ça suppose aussi que le
parlement européen soit écouté donc
qu'il est encore plus de pouvoir ça
suppose que le parlement perrin joue son
rôle et en traîne sur le budget il est
en train de jouer son rôle il et imed
devant ses responsabilités
le conseil européen et le temps que leur
parlement européen à une majorité unie
pas tous les pavés majorité unie et bien
ce parlement peut changer les choses
eh bien merci ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous sur
le plateau d'europe et d'eau bien merci
messieurs d'avoir accepté notre
invitation deux bouts l'europe c'est
donc le titre de votre ouvrage c'est
également tout un programme quant à nous
on se retrouve ici la semaine prochaine
pour europe hebdo d'ici là bonne suite
de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires